Hey, good morning everybody. It's Mike.
It's a Monday morning 9:30 Chicago time
depending on where you are
around the world. Thank you for coming
and joining today's presentation. We'll
be talking about the new Order Flows
Trader 7 that's on gocharting.com. Now,
gocharting.com is a web-based platform.
And what really makes it special is
now you can trade the American markets
through it. It connects to amp, iron
beam, as well as crypto exchanges. So,
you know, if you're in America, it's
something that you should definitely uh
check out. And
what I'm excited to talk about is my
order flow indicators appearing on
gocharting. Okay, so
um you know, just a brief disclaimer,
you know, as we get started because you
know, I do want you to understand you
know, trading does involve risks and you
know, we're all adults here and we
should we all understand that you know,
you shouldn't be trading with money you
can't afford to lose. Now, for those of
you that are new to who I am, my name is
Michael Valtos and you know, I've got
over 25 years trading experience. I
started in the early 90s on the CME
trading floor, you know, back in the
days when there still was a floor. I
started literally at the bottom of the
industry with Dean Witter Reynolds. I
was a runner and you know, eventually I
worked my way up to clerk then after I
realized that the floor trading
um well, I don't say I realized floor
trading was going to end at that time,
but what was happening in the early 90s
was electronic trading was starting and
you know, being a a kid in my 20s, I
realized you know, that's where I wanted
to be. And so I left the trading floor
to work on the trading desk at Dean
Witter. I worked overnights trading
Globex project day and NYMEX COMEX
access.
Um the electronic markets as well as the
international markets that were open
overnight.
After several years trading on the
macro trading desk there, I left to join
EDF Man in Chicago, right? Which EDF Man
is a big English trading company has
been around since the 1700s.
Um then eventually I left to get my
Eurex trading license at Commerzbank. I
was a licensed Eurex trader, one of only
a handful in Chicago at that time. Um
what was happening was Eurex was trying
to break into the US markets and the
Board of Trade
said no, you couldn't do that and they
put a moratorium on um
Eurex terminals in the US, but
fortunately I already had my Eurex
license and um I we at Commerzbank we
had a Eurex terminal. So, I was I was
one of only a handful of people that can
trade Eurex
um directly through the exchange not
having to go through a broker. Then
after 9/11, I took some time off, joined
Cargill.
Um I was headed to futures trading desk
in Chicago and eventually I went to
Singapore to set up a trading desk for
Cargill when the exchange closed there.
And after doing that, then I joined JP
Morgan in Singapore where I spent close
to a decade there as vice president of
futures trading.
And 2013 I left JP Morgan,
started trading for myself. I was using
order flow and after a while, you know,
I met up with a programmer and I said,
"Hey, you know what, this is how I use
order flow. Can you put it into
um
software so that it would help to
analyze the order flow for me, right?
Because I mean, you know, at the end of
the day, what is nice about
software is, you know, you can program
it to to show you certain things and
there were certain things in the order
flow that I like to look at and we
started putting it into software and
that became the Order Flows uh
trader software. Now, originally it
wasn't meant to be sold. It was just
meant for my own trading, but talking to
traders, they saw it, they wanted it and
that's how Order Flows grew from there.
So, just a little bit of background on
me so you know, you understand you know,
where I'm coming from and the tools that
you know, we've created and and why
we've created them.
So,
the nice thing about gocharting is you
can say goodbye to cluttered desktops
and hello to uh gocharting which is an
all-in-one web-based solution for
trading as well as order flow analysis.
Now, I don't have any slide decks. You
know, this is it. This is basically all
the slides I get. I got two more with
the link to something which I'll share
with you.
So, what I'm going to do is I'm just
going to pull in the gocharting platform
here really quick. I'll just go through
everything here in in real time. This
presentation is being recorded. Okay, so
you know, you could refer back to it in
case you have to leave. And you know, it
will be posted up on on YouTube later.
So, you know, gocharting is a web-based
platform and and the beauty of having a
web-based platform is you can
access it from anywhere. You know, I
have trading platforms that run on
desktops and
what sucks about that is you got to be
sitting at your desk. You got to be
sitting in in you know, your office or
wherever or you know, maybe you're
you're on a laptop or something, but the
beauty is you could use gocharting on a
mobile device. You can use it on a
tablet. You can use it even on your
phone. I got a Samsung fold you know,
with that big screen and you know, when
I'm out and I want to keep track of the
markets if if I'm
you know, even if I'm not
actively following the markets or
trading, I still like to keep an eye on
on what's taking place in the market and
you know, that's the beauty of um having
a
a web-based platform. Okay? And again,
you know, if you're traveling, it is
great because no matter what country
you're in, as long as you got an
internet connection, you can access
gocharting. Okay? So,
um let's just pull up a chart here real
real quick. Okay? It's really simple to
use. Okay? You'll see here.
Um close this down.
Now, depending on what you have set up
as your default, mine mine comes up as
nifty, but you know, I'll just type in E
E-minis ES. Okay?
And
oops, I got to think I got to log in
first.
Give me a second here.
Let me go back here cuz I didn't log in.
Um you just log in.
It's really simple. Again, you can
create an account
um
on gocharting. It's very simple. Okay,
so there we go. So, it should say charts
before it said login. Um go to products,
go to charts.
And here we go. Okay, so again, I don't
I don't uh
You know, in the future I'll do
something on nifty, but I think most of
you guys here today are are more
interested in some of the US contracts.
So, we'll we'll start with uh
the E-minis. Okay?
And just really quick, here we go. I
just like to expand it out.
All right. Now,
there's a few things to note with
gocharting. Okay?
Is tick size. Okay? So, what you got to
do
is
there's this little cog here for
settings.
Okay? And I'll go to order flow because
this is going to
um manage your your tick setting on your
chart. Now,
there's auto mode which I believe is the
default and then there's disable it.
Then you got to set your actual tick
settings. Now, for futures,
all right, I like to use one tick as the
minimum setting.
This is a five-minute chart. Let me just
go down to a one-minute chart so it's a
little easier to manage.
Okay, so here we go. So, every tick is
showing up. If you you know, if you're
on a market like say Nasdaq
that you know, has a big
ranges per bar, you might want to
um aggregate that into you know, four
ticks into one tick and then what that
means, let me just
I'll show you here real quick. Pull up a
Nasdaq chart.
Okay, you see you can't see the
footprint because there's so many prices
um you know, per tick or sorry, so many
levels per bar, so many price levels per
bar. What
what some traders do, what they like to
do is they like to aggregate cuz you
know, if you especially if you're
watching a dome on
Nasdaq, you know that
you know, like here's 19608, there might
not be any trades till here, you you
know,
eight and a half or something cuz it
just jumps around. If you're if you're
looking at the dome, you'll notice that
it basically the way it trades on a dome
is basically 19605
at 606,
right? So, what what some traders will
do is they'll just make this tick size
four.
Okay?
That way it's just it's more makes more
sense for them. Okay? Now, when you're
aggregating
ticks, I call it aggregating ticks, you
know, I I'd still look at the same
things in the order flow. Okay? So,
let's just really quick go back to
E-minis.
You know, if you're new to trading US
futures markets,
honestly, I I don't suggest jumping
right into Nasdaq just because of the
volatility and then a lot of traders
can't always deal with that. It's just
just moving around way too much for
them. But you know, contracts like
E-minis,
MES,
uh the currencies on the CME, you know,
British pound, euro currency, Japanese
yen and even
interest rates on the Board of Trade are
all good starting points for for
traders. Okay? So, once you
have your chart up,
Okay, now I'll be honest, mine is a
default. If you were to start from what
we'll do is I'll I'll start from scratch
here.
Okay.
And
I'll I'll delete this just so I could
show you how to how to get everything up
and running very quick. Okay.
So
you know, say you're starting here,
right? Your your candlestick chart. I'll
just show you how easy it is to set up.
You know, you have a a simple
candlestick chart and you want to add
the Order Flows Trader software um to
it. Well, first thing you should do is
change the type of chart, right? You see
here you got um different types of
charts. You got, you know, line break,
Heikin-Ashi, Renko, um range bars.
Uh I use
go to cluster. Okay, cluster is a basic
footprint chart. And the Order Flows
Trader software will run on top of the
footprint chart. Cuz if you're looking
at a footprint chart,
um you know, you're looking at the
volume traded on the bid, the volume
traded on the offer, and for
most traders, especially traders that
are beginning with order flow, you don't
know what you're looking at, right?
You're not going to be able to make
heads or tails of this because you
haven't learned it. It it's
it's a way of analyzing the flow of
trades that are going through the
market. Now,
when people talk about order flow,
you know, there's always the question of
the DOM, the heat map, or the footprint.
Right? This is a footprint. The DOM is
the depth of market.
Right? Which is showing you the volume
on the bid and the volumes below the
bid, the volumes on the offer, and the
volumes above the offer. Right? And then
you can see as it trades. But problem
with that is, right? We know that that
can be manipulated. People enter
bids and offers and pull bids and
offers. What uh depth of what uh price
ladder or depth of market is showing is
traders' intent. Right? Yeah, you know,
if the market is trading like right now
we're trading um basically 5592.
But if
the market is going to trade, you know,
5595, you know, there's some sellers up
here. Well, yeah, when we're we're
trading 92, three points lower, if it
trades up to 95,
yeah, I I'd I'd probably like to be a
seller, too, when we're trading at at
92. But what you see often times in the
DOM as you start getting closer, people
realize that there's
um some momentum picking up that the
market is coming up to 95. Now, there's
guys that's trying to sell at 95. They
don't want to. Why why should they sell
at 95 if the market's going up? Then
they'll move it up to 96, 97, etc.
Um and the same thing with the heat map.
That that that's just more of a visual
look at the DOM.
But what makes the uh footprint so
unique is that
it is actually tracking the trades as
they you know, as they occur, right? The
actual volume that's traded in the
market. And that's important because
when someone trades, puts on a trade,
they're committed to the market.
Eventually they've got to get out of
that trade. Okay.
So once you've added your your cluster
chart, you can see it up in here. Right?
It says cluster.
Now you could just
I'll just show you what this is. There's
these three layers, these little um
squares. These are what they call
layers. Okay? This is where you're going
to control a lot of stuff. So if you
want to edit it, right? And then you can
see what you have um in here.
Um there there's a lot of things in here
that you can adjust. I like to keep it
simple, volume point of control. I like
to use uh value areas.
But they also have tools like um you
know, unfinished auction, if you want to
look at that, um candle body market high
low markers, COT marker, delta
divergence, cumulative delta. But I'll
get into some of these later. But really
what you want to do now, okay, is now
you're going to add
um the Order Flows Trader software. So
you see on here order flow. All right?
You're going to click on this thing that
says FX study.
Open it up.
Order flow. Okay? And you see this one
here it says Order Flows Trader. Okay?
So just click on that.
And then you're going to go back to the
layers.
And I'll minimize this and you'll see it
right here. Order Flows Trader. All
right? And these are the tools
that are inside here. And again, you
know, each one of these tools is
something that
I've used in my own trading, right?
That's why it's there. It's to me it's
is very important information in the
market. So exhaustion prints, um
imbalance thresholds, ratios, slingshot
point of control, market weakness, um
sequencing, market sweeps, primary point
of controls, zero prints, inverse
imbalance, multiple imbalance, buying
and selling tails, thin prints. Okay.
And really quick, let me show you
something else. Go to back to the study.
Go to uh hey, where is it here?
Back to order flow. Click on bar
statistics. Okay? And what that is, it's
this information sort of at the bottom
of the chart. Okay? And just uh I'll
just run you through some things really
quick here.
Now, the bar statistics, right? Is the
important for me that there's a lot of
statistics you can put on here.
But one thing that I've had uh
GoCharting add is these thresholds.
Okay? So you know, there's to me the
important parts of the bar statistics is
the volume, the volume for the bar,
you know, the delta,
which is the difference between the net
buying and net selling in a bar. Or
rather, let me
take rephrase that. The net aggressive
trading taking place in the bar between
the aggressive buyers and the aggressive
sellers. Okay? So if a bar is has strong
negative delta, I know that obviously
aggressive sellers were in a bar. If
it's got positive delta, aggressive
traders were in the bar. Okay?
And then there's max and min delta,
right? Which are very important because
that shows you how strong it was at one
point in the bar. Max delta is how
strong the aggressive buying was in a
bar. Min delta is how strong
aggressive selling was in the bar.
Okay? So max delta can never be
negative, min delta can never be
positive.
And
there's also a delta
percentage that I like to look at. Okay?
Delta percentage
threshold is basically the
think of it as as the strength of delta
relative to the volume of the bar. Okay?
And there are um default settings, 95,
five, and 25. Okay? And really what that
does, it it tells me like for example,
this bar here, you can see this is the
delta percentage, 46
.03. It's magenta color. So that's
telling me that
the aggressive buying, this delta of 609
against the volume of 1.32
K, you know, 1,300,
is very strong. Right? Cuz again, you
know, every bar has a delta.
Every bar has a volume cuz there's going
to be volume traded.
But most of the time it doesn't really
matter, right? It's just
the market doing what the market's
supposed to do. It's it's
facilitating trade. But there's times
where it's just very strong,
either positive or negative, that that
can give you a clue as to the near-term
move of the market. And you can see here
the market um you know, started going up
from that area.
Um you know, some of the other numbers
just really quick,
discuss them here.
All right? You can see this delta is
cyan color, cyan color.
This one is magenta color. We got
magenta color, magenta color. If it is
cyan color, this blue color is telling
you that the the delta number itself is
a strong delta number. And when you
start seeing numbers like this around a
low, this is a nice swing low came in
here,
what is telling you
aggressive buying is coming into the
market. Right? So I mean, if if you just
see the cyan color delta,
then you know the delta is strong. But
when you see it sort of coming in right
around a low that's been made,
what what's that telling you? Right? You
have aggressive selling coming into a
low, which is what you expect to see,
right? This bar here has got this
magenta delta, minus 1.5
K. So I know that that's a strong
negative delta, but we're already going
down, which is what you like to see.
Now you see it sort of
petered out. This bar has got a small
delta of minus five. This one's got a
strong delta of minus 383. But
aggressive buying is starting to come
in, and not just aggressive buying,
because this delta could have just been,
you know, 200. Yeah, I wouldn't blink an
eye at it. But it's 684. It's it's
magenta color. And the reason what makes
it so strong is because it's closing
near our max delta of 694. It's closing
within 95%. So I know
market's come down
on strong aggressive selling. Now it's
you got to be thinking, okay, are we
going to keep going down, or maybe are
we going to go sideways or reverse. But
now that I know
there's strong aggressive buying coming
in by looking at this delta,
and again, you know, if you weren't
using these tools, you sort of have to
just stare at your chart and try to
figure, is this delta, does this one
matter? Is this important? But I know
that since it's colored um cyan, I know
that it's strong.
Okay? But, you know, maybe you're not
convinced that uh this bar is strong
because it's a small green candle, you
know, it opened,
went a little bit lower, went a higher,
and pulled back.
Okay? Well, then the next bar it's a
nice big green bar.
And it's got a nice strong positive
delta 764. It's also
cyan color. So I know it's closing near
its max delta. That is a sign of
strength in the market. And again, where
is the strength coming in? It's coming
in at a low because remember
what price is, right? Price
goes up, it goes down. If it goes up,
it's going to attract sellers. If it
goes down, it wants to attract buyers
because price will go down down down
down until it could attract buyers into
the market.
And once it attracts buyers into the
market, what happens? Well, you know,
buying is taking place and strong
aggressive buying, the market goes up.
Okay, so let's take a look at some of
the Order Flow Suite Trader settings,
okay? And
you know, there's a lot of tools on
here. Do I have People always ask, you
know, what what's the best tool to use?
Well,
there's a lot of different tools, but
really what you want to focus on
because, you know, not everybody trades
the same market. Not everybody trades
the same chart. Some people like to use
a 1-minute chart, some people use a
range-based chart, etc. Um
and again, you know, different markets.
So it really depends on what you're
trading
as to what you want to use. But one of
the ones that I love to use the most
is exhaustion prints, okay? And I'm
going to
enable it here and there's a threshold,
okay? So you can set a number that you
want. Default is set to nine, which
basically tells you if
a volume of nine or lower so nine,
eight, seven, six all the way down to
zero appear at the edge of a bar that
it's going to be bullish if it's a green
up candle or bearish if it's a red down
candle, okay?
So you could see here.
All right, we had a nice
I'll just go back a little bit, okay? So
we had a nice little swing low, market
started going up. You had an exhaustion
print here
on this candle
but market doesn't go any lower.
And it goes inside and pokes back up.
Market's going up, exhaustion print,
exhaustion print as the market's going
up. That's what you want to see. But
anytime a market starts to turn, right?
If we get a swing high like here, start
to come off, I'm looking for any signs
of market exhaustion because remember,
we just went from
basically 5581
all the way up to 91, a 10-point move.
Okay, and
you know, markets rotate, right? We have
moves from lows to highs, swing lows to
to swing highs.
And you know, in the past, it seemed
like S&P's, you know, in the past, I
would say like two or three years ago,
S&P
rotation was, you know, basically
between three to four points. Now I
think it's
now that we're trading
so much higher, I think the rotations
have gotten bigger, more like almost
double that, you know, six to seven,
eight points. So it's a nine-point move.
So it's it's one rotation.
So I'm looking for any signs of a
potential reversal and I get it right
here with my exhaustion prints.
Right?
And the market starts a nice move down.
Now I'll talk about
this a little bit later. These are
bearish point of port controls. And as
you see, market is going up, exhaustion
print, exhaustion print as the market's
going up. Right? There was one here,
didn't cause a reversal. Now
that's the exhaustion prints.
Imbalance reversal.
I'll just turn Let me turn something on
here on Cluster. I have
Where is the imbalances? Show
imbalances. I got imbalances turned off,
okay?
So that's uh
imbalance is a tool that's built into
the default
of
GoCharting, okay? They they
put a few
of
the
tools that we have in Order Flow Suite
Trader, I've asked them to make it sort
of a default so everyone that's using a
cluster chart of GoCharting has access
to it because some of my tools are are
built around it and I think that you
know, if you're into order flow, you
need something, you know, you need to be
able to look at imbalances. You need to
be looking at point of controls and
value areas. So I've added the value
areas. Now what I'm going to do is going
to
add
the imbalance reversal. So first
I will
disable it so you can see here, okay?
Now I'm going to add it here.
All right.
So if you noticed it or let me see if I
turn off the imbalance here just to make
it a little bit easier to see.
Now you need to have imbalances on,
okay?
So
All right, where am I here? I got to
scroll down here.
Hang on. I don't want to get people
confused here because there's two.
There's imbalance inverse volume
imbalance
and there's
imbalance reversal. So imbalance
reversal
is, you know, when you look at
Well, let me just turn
when you're looking at the
footprint, right? You're going to see
blue numbers
and you're going to see red numbers,
right? And you're going to have the
this
box, it's orange box. Now that's a
selling imbalance, right? If it's a red
number
in the bar, if it's a
blue number in the bar
it's going to be a buying imbalance. You
have selling imbalance, buying
imbalance, right? So aggressive buying,
aggressive selling, okay? I like to have
the box in there just You could just You
could take that orange box out if you
like if you just want to have, say
the just just showing it, right? If here
just showing the colors, if make that
transparent.
Okay, so it's just showing the buying
imbalance and the selling imbalance,
okay? Now
adding the
Close this.
Imbalance reversal, right? Because
you're seeing here on green candles,
normally what you're expecting to see is
buying imbalances. Just as on
red candles, what you're expecting to
see is selling imbalances.
By adding this, you're going to see it's
going to highlight to you where there is
um
selling imbalances in the green candles
or buying imbalances in the red candles.
Okay? And that's important information
that you could use for your trading, all
right? Because again, it's what you're
looking for is things that are
not normal order flow.
If there's not normal order flow taking
place, then it's telling you there's
probably
a big order going through, okay? Or
maybe the collective of traders are just
slowly changing their mind because
really what order flow helps you do is
is follow what the big money is doing,
right? And
it The way to think of it is, right?
I mean, no pun intended, but the flow of
a river, okay, is is is up.
Okay, that's why you're seeing Well, in
this case, it's the market trend is
going up, right? The flow is going up.
You have the buying imbalances.
Okay, now all of a sudden you have a
selling imbalance on the green bar and
the market's still going up. Well,
what's that telling you, right? The
selling imbalance
is basically telling you that there's
somebody in here
that's chasing the market up or bidding
the market up, right? Because it's a
strong bid that's absorbing all the
selling that's taking place to help move
this market down. So yeah, you expect to
see buying imbalances on a market that's
going up. That's
what helps drive the market higher, but
what helps to keep the market higher
is those selling imbalances, right? That
is demand, you know, coming in, people
bidding the market to add support. Just
as if a market is dropping like here,
supply coming into the market to help
push the market down, right? To to cap
it from going any higher.
So that's the imbalance reversal.
Now ratios, okay? Ratios is a big part
of my trading.
And every bar, right, has volume in it,
okay?
So every bar is going to have a ratio.
So there's two. There's Order Flow
critical ratios, there's all Order Flow
ratios.
And
if it's a bullish ratio, meaning it's a
green bar, it's going to have a bullish
ratio. It'll appear on the bottom of the
bar. If it's a red candle,
okay, it'll appear on the top of the
candle, okay? That's In case you're
wondering why some appear on the bottom,
some appear on the top, it's because
what the ratio does, it's reading the
order flow near the top of a bar that's
a red candle that's going lower in the
bottom of a bar of a green candle that's
going higher. That's why it prints it on
the bottom, prints it on the top. Now
like I said, every
bar
has a ratio.
All All because it has order flow.
But not every
bars ratio, again, matters. All right,
cuz a lot of times, you know,
the market exists to facilitate trade,
to transfer risk from one party to
another. But what we've found is there
are ratios, certain ratios that meet
certain requirements that are that are
critical, that are important for
traders. That would be the order flow
critical ratios. Okay, so you see here,
bearish.
Right, bearish, bullish. As the market
is going up. And
what makes one critical as opposed to
not, or what makes one important as to
not? Well, there are certain thresholds,
right? If it's above um 30
and above or if it's below
um
0.69
to zero. It can't be a ratio can't be
negative, okay?
And
how you use it, right? Critical ratios
is you know that you have, if it's below
0.69
so if it's 0.69 and zero
anywhere in between there, it's telling
you there's price defense in the bar,
right? This is price defense. This is
price defense. Um let's see if there's
price exhaustion here.
All right, I'm just looking at the
critical ratios.
Okay, price exhaustion cuz it's above um
30. This is 33. This is 32. Now
you know, sometimes people ask me
is if a ratio
for example
better to show you here. Um
We'll take a look at the 10 years real
quick.
This is a five-year
five-minute chart.
Sometimes
you know, a ratio might be very big, 314
here, okay? As opposed to 33.
Um
266,
right? 52.
It's a ratio.
Okay, so 50 432 here
is not more important than 52, right?
Really what matters is that it's
a blue color, right? That it that it's
appearing there as a critical ratio.
Right? Not that 432 or 911 is much
better than 52. No, it it's a ratio, so
um um you're just going off of, you
know, really what
the ratio is, not the intensity of it.
Okay, so let's just go back here to
e-minis.
Um let's just sort of run through these.
Now, slingshot point of control.
This is a
point of control setup.
Let's go back to the cash time here. See
if there's a slingshot point of control.
I think there's one right here.
No, that's a prominent point of control.
Slingshot point of control is basically
Just trying to find one here for you.
Okay, like right here. This is a
slingshot point of control. So you got
two up bars, all right? Um
Let me turn off this.
Okay.
And make it a little bit easier to see
here.
Turn off that. Um so slingshot point of
control.
It's it's a bullish It's telling you
it's a point of control that's bullish,
okay?
So you can see here, it will highlight
it in green if it's a bullish one. If it
was bearish, it would be red color. And
let me just put it on here to explain a
little further. Every bar has a point of
control.
Okay? And generally, you know, in green
bars, market's going up, point of
control is going to be higher than the
previous bars point of control. Just as
if a market is going down, the point of
control is going to be lower in the red
bars. You know, here's red, lower point
of control, lower point of control.
Here's green, right? Point of control,
point of control.
But this one came in a little bit lower.
And what we found in the order flow is
when you have
you know, two green bars, second bar's
got a lower point of control
than the first one.
That's important cuz what's happening is
this market is going up.
Right? Now it starts to pull back a bit.
Not only it pulls back, but it puts in
heavier volume on that pull back. Um in
that bar or the bar's volume is heavier
towards the bottom and that you have a
lower point of control. Point of control
is the price level in the bar with the
most volume.
Okay? And that actually is bullish
because it's a pull back, people are
buying the dip.
And you see the market um you know, went
up from in the next bar just from
basically 97 and a half all the way up
to um you know, one and a half. You
know, that was a four-point move just in
the next bar by itself.
Okay? And again, you know, if you're
watching the order flow, maybe you
notice it, maybe you don't.
All right? But having a tool that's
highlighting to you that's say saying,
"Hey, you know what?
You have something
interesting happening in the order flow,
you might want to pay attention to it,
right? You might want to maybe you get a
nice scalp
of a a few points. I'm not talking
ticks, I'm talking points, all right? In
the market.
Market weakness. Okay, now mar- market
weakness.
Let me just
put some add some colors on here.
Let's see if there's any market weakness
today.
Coming in here, okay?
Here's some market weakness right here,
right? This is bullish one right here,
bearish one up here.
Okay, let me expand that out a bit.
This
up arrow is bullish, this down arrow is
bearish. Okay, so the colors
um I put them in backwards, but uh
let's see here.
Change that to a blue color.
Change that to a red color. There we go.
Bearish, bullish. What it's doing,
right? Is it's analyzing the delta,
telling you that this move up
is over, right? It's getting weak.
All right, that's why it's called market
weakness and you're going to look for
the market to go down from there. Just
as here
right? Sort of going sideways, but it's
telling you that
you know, what's taking place in the
market
is weakening in this sense, the
the selling that's taking place. Now
again, this is a market that's going
sideways, it does not giving you much
direction, but what market weakness does
it it analyzes delta because it delta
tells you the difference between
aggressive buying and aggressive
selling.
And
if you know that aggressive buying is
weakening, chances are
the market's going to sell off.
Just as if aggressive selling, which is
take happening here
is weakening, chances are the market's
going to go up. And you can see it went
up from you know, this is a 7:00 in the
morning.
So not a lot of you know, I'm on a
Monday, so not a lot of activity yet and
market's going down. You got
the the bullish
strength that was here is weakening.
And so you can expect potential move
down, okay?
So that's that's market weakness. Um
oops.
Let me get in here to
sequencing. Okay.
Sequencing, let me uh scroll over to the
end.
Okay, oops.
So there's two types of sequencing.
There's bullish sequencing and bearish
sequencing, okay? And it's best seen
here. This is bearish, this is red.
This blue box with the green inside is
bullish.
So, you know, whenever there's a trade
that takes place, right? The volume
shows up in the footprints.
Okay?
And
what sequencing does is is it analyzes
the actual volume that's trading
because, you know, a lot of time the
volume is pretty sporadic, right? 54,
137, 31, 71, 77, 220
you know, 224
or sorry, 244
and it's just a little bit all over the
place. What the sequencer does is it
analyzes
you know, the volume that's being traded
on the bid, the volume that's being
traded on the offer.
And if there is volume
okay, that is
subsequently higher and higher volume on
the way down or higher and higher volume
on the way up that's being cleared out
that is what we call an order flow
sequence.
And you can see here, one, two, three,
four, five levels. It clears that out
subsequent higher volume. So it's
telling you is, you know
traders are
taking out more and more volume in a
direction. And you see that yeah, nice
little sell off here.
It's doing it again here, this on the
way back up. Okay? And
more and more, and you see
the market had a nice rally from there.
Well, doesn't look like it did,
but obviously
went up here, you got another issue,
this another instance of sequencing
taking place here.
Um
just you know, about 20 minutes ago.
Now, a lot of these tools are meant for,
you know, short-term direction. I I like
to trade more on a short-term chart.
You know, 1 minute, sub 1 minute.
I just find, you know, order flow is cuz
it it's measuring the actual order flow
that's taking place in the market.
And that information is best used as
fresh as possible.
So, the next one I'll talk about is
market sweep.
Okay? It's right here. Market sweep. And
you'll see there's a threshold of
25 and a stack count of three.
Okay. Now, you can adjust these, okay,
but I'll just show you really quick with
these defaults. Cuz again, depending on
the market that you're trading,
um you know, if you're trading Nasdaq,
25 might be quite high.
You probably want to make it a little
bit lower. But you can see here, this is
a
sweep that's taking place, right? And
it'll draw out this little zone
over, you know, the next several bars
for you just cuz when you see a sweep
take place, what is a sweep?
What's a big order going through the
market, basically clearing out the bids
if it's a sell, and clearing out the
offers if it's a buy.
So,
here on
before this move down,
well,
in this bar, right? There's a sweep
takes place. So, someone came in,
cleared out all this these bids here.
Okay?
Then you can see there's a nice strong
offer
right on the bottom of the sweep.
Someone came in, you know, the market is
trading, you know, 87 and a half and
basically just said, you know, sell it
down to, you know, six, six or six and a
quarter or six right here. Just cleaning
out these things. You know, it it's
funny because
you know, there's there's traders out
there that think
um you know, the institutions are
you know, are are out to get them,
right? That they're they're gunning for
their stops, etc. But, you know, to be
honest,
for us retail traders, right? And and I
used to be an institutional trader for
many years.
These little orders in the book, if
you're looking in the the the depth of
the market, right? The dome, the the
price ladder, you know,
it's just stuff that's in the way.
All right? So, if, you know, if you're a
big trader and you think, "Hey, you know
what? man, this market's
overpriced.
I want to be short this."
You just come in and you just clean
everything out, you know? This nine
lots, the 29, the 22, that's nothing,
right? But, you know, the the the small
retail trader, "Oh, they're they're
gunning for my stop." Your your stop is
too conscious. They they ain't, right?
It's just just something that's
you know,
in the way, you know? You're like we're
like we're like ants to the
institutional traders.
Unfortunately, there's a lot of us, so
we're a lot of ants.
This is a bearish
sweep. This is a bullish sweep, right?
And I like to use these as support and
resistance levels because I know there
was a big buyer at this level. And to
me, it's important to see if it holds.
Cuz if a sweep holds,
then I know that, "Hey, you know what?
Maybe now the information is coming out
into the market." Because the way
information We all like to think
everybody has access to this same
information. We It It's just not a level
playing field in that sense.
Not everybody
has access to the same information. And
unfortunately, the game is stacked
against us because
you know, the the big trading firms, the
banks have an access to information we
don't have. They have a staff of
analysts, economists,
parsing all sorts of information that we
we rely on Twitter,
basically. I mean, you can't, you know,
Facebook, forget about it. Forget about
watching CNBC or Bloomberg TV. Um
but the big institutional traders, they
have access to information that we don't
have, and by the time we get it, it's
too late. So, sometimes when you see a
big burst of
activity in the market,
often times it's preceded by a sweep. Um
could be somebody
got a piece of information
that is bullish or bearish for the
market and they're
trading that information. It's coming
through the market, right? Now, it
doesn't mean that every single sweep,
bullish or bearish, is going to work out
exactly right away. You know, this one
just went sideways on you before going
up, but you can see often times it does
give you nice near-term direction.
Okay? And then when you combine it with
other factors such as, you know, is
there a buying imbalances taking place?
What's point of control? What's the
delta doing?
Um
then understanding the market just
becomes a heck of a lot easier. Okay?
All right. So, let's work through this.
Prominent point of control is one of my
favorite tools
that I ever uh
ever came up with, I guess.
And
you know, this is uh
based off the point of control. Point of
control is the price level in the bar
with the most volume. Now, every bar has
a point of control,
assuming every bar's got volume, but not
every point of control matters, right? I
explained that in the um
slingshot point of control.
But you can see here, this is a bearish
prominent point of control. It's magenta
color. It has this nice line drawn out.
Because I know that this the volume
that's taking place in here
is bearish. There's another one right
here.
And a PPC is this nice, you know,
10-point 15-point move down here, you
know, basically from 90
all the way down to 75, even below that.
Okay?
And there's bullish ones here, bullish
one here.
It's a bearish one there.
It's a nice bearish one here, bullish
here. And again, you know, how I like to
trade these is, you know, I watch them
where they're coming in. Not that
there's just a prominent point of
control. You know, I like to get and I
like to see, you know, if if we're
hanging around a high, this is I believe
our high of the day here,
and we can't get any higher, and then I
see a bearish prominent point of control
come in. Yeah, I'm probably going to
want to be short.
Okay? You see the market is is going
down just as
um you know, up here, we hit our swing
high,
starting to come off a bit. I have the
exhaustion print here.
I stack sell imbalance here. I got a
bearish prominent point of control.
And the market's moving down.
Okay?
But prominent point of controls is uh
one of the favorite tools that I have in
my arsenal. Now, zero prints, okay? Now,
depending on the market, like if you're
trading, say uh E-minis,
you don't get a lot of zero prints
because what a zero print is,
it's it's dependent on the volume,
right? And E-minis, you know, we we
trade a
we trade a lot of volume. So, let me
just change the contract just to make it
a little bit easier to see. Go to euro
currency.
Um
you know, euro currency actually also
trades a lot of decent volume,
but
what you want to see,
okay?
Let's go here. So, there's some zero
prints. But, let me change it to
Well, let's change it to a 5-minute
chart.
Okay, so here, this is bullish zero
print. It's coming in here, here, here.
So, let me just expand this out.
So, when you enable zero prints,
right? It's right here.
For bullish ones, it's going to be a
green up arrow. For bearish ones, it'll
be a red down arrow. And basically, what
you're looking at is the print of zero
either in this price level or this one
on the bottom.
Price level of a bar or the second price
level of a bar. And basically, it's bad
structure.
What's happened is
it sort of ticked a little bit lower,
and then the aggressive buying came in.
And there was no counter trade. That's
the zero. Okay? And And that's bullish
for the market. You see the market had
this nice quick jump up off of that. So,
I don't know if there's a any bearish
ones here. Here's some bearish ones.
Again, right here, coming right off this
high up here.
Right? As we're heading down, zero print
right here, zero print here, zero print
here.
Um So, the next one I'll talk about is
inverse
imbalance, okay? And that's
uh pretty easy to see.
Well, let's go back to E-minis here.
Okay?
Keep it uniform on uh E-minis.
Come back to the 1-minute chart.
Uh let's go back to the the day session,
where we are right now here.
Okay, so
Inverse imbalance, it'll draw these
little arrows. If it's bearish, if it's
bullish here.
Okay?
And
what it's doing is it's
measuring the
Well, it's not measuring it. It's
looking at the order flow in the bar.
And
if you have a red candle with buying
imbalances, right? It's similar to the
imbalance reversal, but imbalance
reversal is when the
the imbalance comes in at a certain
spot.
Um
with the inverse imbalance, it could
come in anywhere in the bar. So, on a
red candle, you see down here, right?
The imbalance is at the bottom.
This red candle, imbalance is at the
bottom.
On this green candle, imbalance is on
the bottom, but this is actually also an
imbalance reversal. So, it's imbalance
reversal, it will still still show up.
But
if it's inverse imbalance
it could be anywhere in the red candle.
And again, you know, what that signifies
is
supply or demand coming into the market.
So,
if when you think in terms of supply and
demand, well, how do you what do you
know about supply and demand?
Okay?
So, for example, if a market is coming
down, right? You expect to see supply in
the market, right? So, I'm not shocked
to see here, right?
The imbalance the inverse imbalance as
the market is going down.
But now as the market is starting to go
up
to see demand come in here.
Okay? So, that's what the inverse
imbalance will help show you is demand
coming into the market.
Okay? Um
let me just drink some water here.
Now
multiple imbalances, okay?
Is that put them on? You can see this
box drawn around. Now, there's two types
of Let's say two types of imbalances,
but you know, on the cluster chart,
right? On your regular footprint chart
you have
this here. Support resistance, okay?
Which is basically stacked buying and
selling imbalances, right? This is a
stack buying imbalance
here and here. Right? And what that is
is
it's three or more imbalances stacked
nice and neatly on top of each other,
right? That's what
a stacked imbalance is, right? By
definition, they're stacked on each
other.
And that's good, right? It's a great
tool for for trading. I mean, if you if
you look at, you know, where they come
in, right? You see here in bullish
market activity, there's a lot of stack
buying imbalances, right? Just as, you
know, market is about to sell off, stack
selling imbalance.
However
there are bars that have what we call
multiple imbalances.
Okay? Which is three or more imbalances
spread out in the bar.
That's not stacked
on top of each other.
Now, does that mean that stacked
imbalances are more important than
non-stacked imbalances? Well
let me show you.
Here.
Okay?
Market is coming down. Stack multiple
you know, stack selling imbalance up
here. Then you got multiple imbalances,
multiple imbalances, multiple
imbalances, multiple imbalances.
Selling imbalances. How do I know?
Because these are red candles, so it's
looking at the selling imbalances.
Well, that's what you expect to see on a
market that's moving down, right?
Aggressive selling. That's what's
helping drive the market lower.
All right? So
you are going to see multiple imbalances
on moves down. Just as you're going to
see multiple buying imbalances on moves
up. But this is where it gets
interesting.
Is
you come into a low again, right?
This is a nice low today. Nice trading
low for order flows traders.
And you got multiple buying imbalances
coming in
the second bar off the low. Your stack
buying imbalance doesn't come in till
another two bars later.
And another five points higher. So,
where would you rather get in? Closer to
the low or a little further off the low?
Well you're going to be better off
getting in as close to the low as
possible.
Why? Because that's going to minimize
your risk. Because, you know, if you're
a swing trader and you're you're buying
off the low, what is your stop going to
be? Well, it's going to be probably just
below the low.
So, if you were to buy as close to to it
as possible
rather than another five points away,
that's just an extra five points of
risk.
Okay? And then that's the beauty of
multiple imbalances is, you know,
anytime you're up near a high or a low,
again, you know, here.
Are you you got the swing low that was
made?
Then the bar afterwards, you got a nice
multiple buying imbalances coming in
here.
Got a nice little trade to the upside
there.
You know, got a little swing high
here.
Got some imbalances you could trade.
Now, the next one, um buying tails,
selling tails.
Okay? Now, on E-mini, you're probably
not going to see it a lot, but on a
market like Nasdaq or
let's take a look at YM mini Dow
futures.
Just you're not going to The reason I'm
not I say you're not going to see it a
lot on
um
you you're not going to see it a lot on
the uh
E-minis because E-minis do a great job
of uh distributing volume, okay? So,
that's why you're not necessarily going
to see it
uh
so much, okay?
But
here we go.
Okay? So, buying and selling tails,
right? Disabled.
Enabled.
And again
what a tail is is this poor structure in
the market.
Okay?
It's telling you this
market basically Well, here. Let me just
show you the example.
This is a tail right here at this swing
low here.
Okay? It puts the box around it, right?
Box, no box.
Box, okay?
And when you see a tail, especially
coming in at at a low
what's happened is
the market just got sold off really
quick and then just snapped back. It's
like an order goes through
almost like a sweep, but it's just like,
you know, someone sell me whatever, five
contracts. Boom, boom, boom. And
instantly he's back up. It just snaps
back.
Then starts trading higher, right? Next
bar goes higher. You can see here, it's
just straight up.
Okay? This was a selling tail here, but
again, this is like
right on the cash open.
This was a few minutes before the cash
open.
Um
buying tail, buying tail, okay?
But really what you want to be looking
for them at is swing highs and swing
lows, okay?
Turning points in the market.
More of a a reversal indicator. Yeah, up
here we're at a swing high, a clear
swing high.
All right? We we went up. It's not that
every bar that has a buying or selling
tail you take. If you're at a swing
high, you get a tail developed that's
where you want to get short at. Just as
if you're at a low or right around a low
and you get a tail formed
um I don't know if there's one in here.
Any bullish ones to show you.
Not really.
You know, if you have a bullish tail,
you need a green candle with a tail, you
know, coming in around a low, you don't
want to get long. Just as a bearish one,
somewhere near a high, you don't want to
get short.
Okay?
That's tails. And uh let's go back to
E-minis.
Talk about the thin prints. It's another
one of my favorite uh tools, okay?
So, a thin print, all right? Is volume
below a certain threshold in a bar,
okay? And you can see here.
This one is set to five.
Bullish thin print, bullish thin print.
One, two, three, four, right? Generally,
in markets going up, you're going to see
bullish thin prints, okay?
On markets going down
example here.
Bearish thin prints.
One Basically, what it is is volume
below a certain amount, right? Five in
this case.
So, there's one, zero, two, zero.
You know, four. Then on the way up zero.
Five, three.
So
you know, it's a sign of momentum,
right? It's a sign of a market that's
moving fast where there's not
necessarily a lot of volume taking place
in the two-way auction.
Now, again, you know, a lot of these
tools you're going to say, "Hey, you
know what? Why do I need these tools,
right? I could just watch the footprint
myself and and see all this."
Well, you could, you know, if you're
experienced at looking at a footprint
and and have the time
to fully concentrate. Cuz, you know, at
the end of the day, not everybody has
the time to fully concentrate. You know,
there's a lot of distractions in the
world now, you know, there's
your phone, there's Facebook, there's
you know, Twitter, all that stuff um
that if you're sitting here trying to
make
sense of everything that's happening in
real time, very quick, it it could be
hard. You know, some markets trade
faster than others, right? NASDAQ we
know trade faster than others.
But if you have a tool that's going to
help, all right? So, you can just add
these things out here. Okay, so look at
this, right? Thin print,
multiple imbalances,
blood on uh
critical ratios, right? I can see this
bar here.
I can start to make sense of what's
taking place in the market, right? I can
say, well, you know, we just made a
swing low,
starting to come off of it. I've got a
very strong delta, right? That's this
magenta color. I've got a bullish ratio,
0.59 is a blue color showing
that indicates price defense coming in.
Got multiple imbalances. I've got thin
prints, you know, imbalances spread out
in the bar. Got thin prints, which is a
sign of um
momentum coming in.
Right? I've even got, you know, that
inverse imbalance as well here. So, I've
got a bunch of things taking place in
this bar. I know that this bar is very
bullish in terms of order flow. And
where's it coming in?
It's coming in off this swing low here.
You know, it's coming in at, you know,
basically 80 81.
Right in here.
All right?
You know, what happened, right? Market
put in
this nice big rally, right?
From 80s all the way up into the 90s
pretty quick. This is just a simple
1-minute chart.
You know, if you're on a 5-minute chart,
you could even do a you know, you can
even do longer.
But you would be looking at the same
things in the order flow, you know,
signs of
you know, bullish activity or bearish
activity,
especially when it's all sort of
combined together.
Okay?
For the market to keep going up.
All right? So, you know, it just it's in
my opinion it's it's a great tool. Now,
if you're new to order flow,
okay?
We do have a a free course
that you can download. Um I made it
especially for
users. So, it uses the GoCharting
platform. So, that's a basic course, but
what you do is you go to
orderflows.com/gocharting.
Um let me just I'll just
show you really quick here.
Okay,
redirected here in a second.
So, right here, you just enter your name
and email and sign up and then it takes
you to
you know, the page
where you can download um the course or
watch the course online. It's up to you.
I'm going to put the the link in the
chat here. Let me just uh get my chat
going here.
And
also,
okay?
If you I'll put this link in there. If
you go to this page here, orderflows.com
getgocharting, okay? I'm going
to put that link in there, too.
You'll see GoCharting's got something
for you.
And so, this takes you here. Click on
there and go to GoCharting,
okay? Where you can sign up.
And
right now, the OrderFlows Trader Suite.
So, whenever we release new things,
it'll be pushed out to the platform and
it'll be
um
be included in
You know, so when you subscribe to it,
right? Any new updates or new additions
that we make automatically get pushed
out in there, okay? Now,
with uh GoCharting, they do have a
special going on right now for the India
Independence
Day where you get um 30% off their
annual plan,
okay?
And you could access India. There's
if you want to trade CME, the US
products, um
you also get 30% off. Uh crypto forex,
you know, also 30% off
as well. And
again, the third-party the OrderFlows
Trader, which is a third-party um
add-on, you can subscribe through here.
So, you do
need to subscribe to
GoCharting
because that's where you're going to get
your data from.
And as well as subscribe to OrderFlows
Trader,
okay? So, when you subscribe, if you've
already subscribed to GoCharting
and you subscribe to OrderFlows Trader,
please
um use the same email address,
okay? It's just it's uh that way you can
get activated a lot quicker than trying
to figure out um
your actual
email that you used for GoCharting
versus your email for
um OrderFlows Trader cuz sometimes, you
know, they don't match up, right?
Sometimes people have emails like uh
you know,
that that that aren't correlated
whatsoever. Um and it's just hard to get
you started right away. So, it's just
best to use the same
um
email, okay? And like I said, uh
GoCharting
has
other exchanges as well, right? So, for
example, you know, if you're a crypto
guy, okay? And you know, you're into
Bitcoin, right? You see got Coinbase
there's the ones that you can use to
trade
um
the exchanges.
Let me just check is Bybit and Deribit,
I believe,
um
directly through
GoCharting, okay?
So, you can see there's, you know, the
the contracts here,
um but
you know, it
it's it's funny because, you know,
sometimes I get people, hey, can I use
uh
OrderFlows
Trader to trade um
crypto? And I'm like,
people trade crypto? I thought you just
buy it and and and hold it forever.
I know that's that's um that's what I
do. But there are certain tools that I
do like to use
uh for crypto, okay? Now, if you're
using
a footprint on crypto, um
you do
probably going to need to change your
tick manager to auto, right? Because cuz
you know, crypto trades in satoshis,
etc.
Um it's just easier to manage and again,
depending on your chart, this is uh you
know, a 5-minute. If you're on
you know, crypto,
if you're a trader, you know, I actually
have a course on trading order flow with
crypto.
I would look at, you know, if if I was
going to
trade, you know, say a 15-minute chart
or 30-minute chart. I used to keep a
30-minute chart of crypto up. And really
what you want to look for is
turning points in the market, swing
highs or swing lows, okay? And it's not
difficult to identify a swing high or
swing low. And you're going to basically
look at what's taking place in the order
flow at a swing high
or a swing low, right? I like to look at
the tools I like to use um
Well, you're not going to use thin
prints
unless you adjust the volume.
Um I use critical ratios. I like to
use multiple imbalance, inverse
imbalance and, you know, even prominent
uh
points of controls. But again,
when I'm looking at crypto, I like to
look at swing lows or swing highs.
Okay?
This is a 15-minute chart.
Okay? You can see
the inverse imbalance coming in here.
This is just sideways.
Inverse imbalance there, there.
Um you know, you can look at stacked
imbalances, too.
Here's a swing high.
A stacked imbalance coming in at a swing
high, stacked selling imbalance. Then
the next bar, I got the bearish
prominent point of control. So, there's
there's a lot of ways to do it, you
know. I'll probably do
a special uh crypto presentation on this
um later. But I'm going to take a look
at some questions here really quick.
Um
Just bear with me here.
Toby asks, where do we get a
How do we get a hold of your course
trading crypto?
Um
Let's see here. I forgot what it was.
Uh
OrderFlows.
No.
Let me dig it up for you real quick
here.
Um
Mhm.
Bear with me, guys, here. Just
helping this trader out here.
crypto.html.
This one here. I'll just put the link in
there chat.
That's the crypto course. Um
But uh let me just
go through some of these other
questions.
Could you share
share your favorite chart template?
Yeah, I I
could, but I'll just take you through
the setup really quick.
Um
Yeah, I'm not necessarily I know traders
like to use templates.
Um I'm not always a big
advocate in templates because you know,
I like traders to sort of figure out
what they like to look at in the order
flow because at the end of the day, you
know, not everybody trades the same
um
what do you call it? Trades the same
market, trades the same chart.
Or the same speak like me, I like to
trade on
you know, time-based charts. I used to
trade a lot of
um
range-based charts, but now I'm more on
uh time-based charts, okay? So, my
templates change you know, cuz as
traders we evolve.
But just really quick, what I like to
use
I like to use value area. If you want to
just jot these down, critical ratios,
um prominent point of controls,
um
then prints, multiple imbalances, okay?
All right, I also keep stacked
imbalances up, but the beauty is with
gold trading you can share templates.
I'm just making a note here
because what we're going to do with um
not this week, but in September
once we get a little bit more critical
mass going
in terms of subscribers cuz this is
really this is like really the the first
public announcement of gold trading on
on order flows. We sort of had it soft
launched. But now this is sort of the
big push. I'm going to be doing uh
weekly
presentations for the users of gold
trading
that are using order flows trader. So,
we're going to talk about, you know,
ways to use
gold trading you know, and again, you
know, you can come in, ask your
questions. Uh we can discuss chart
setups. You can ask me my opinions on,
you know, is this a good way to approach
the market? It's going to be
uh
every week, I believe.
It's going to be me hosting it. It's not
going to be, you know, somebody else.
So, you could ask your questions
directly to me. Um
But I'm just trying to find the right
time. I think it's, you know, best to do
it probably during live trading hours
as opposed to evening times cuz, you
know,
for some people it's hard and you know,
people in Europe
they're asleep at that time, but we're
going to be doing that starting in
September after the US Labor Day
holidays.
So, um you know, if you're a member,
you'll be invited to all those sessions.
It's it's free of charge, right? It's
basically 1 hour
training with me, okay?
And it's just funny because, you know, a
lot of times people buy software and
they're like, oh, if you want training,
you know, that's extra, but you know,
that's going to be included in there.
Um
Let me take a look here. So, Charles
asked, please show the chart how to use
range chart with order flow.
Okay.
Well, they're they're still working on
the range charts. But I'll discuss that
in in a later one, um Charles, okay?
Where can I see the dome? Usually on the
right side. I don't like to use a dome,
but you I believe you could add the dome
um
on here.
But again, I'm an um I I I want to keep
this on on the order flows trader first,
but um
yeah, you could add a dome, the depth of
market,
okay?
How to access the order flows trader
premium? Well, first you got to
subscribe to it, then you're going to go
to the study
area here and you're going to find order
flow and you just add it, click on it
here.
Okay?
Okay.
Tool set window stuck. Yeah, well,
actually I had the window tool set up
there, but I was talking about stuff on
the other side, the crosshairs where the
crosshairs was, which should have
um been helpful. Um
What courses do you recommend for a
beginner to trade order flow? There are
quite a few courses on your site.
Well, the the the main one, the order
flows trader course is
the best starting point um
to learn order flow. That's basic one,
but again, you know, if you
you can go to uh
What was that page? Gold charting, the
one I put in the chat here.
This one.
It's in the chat. Order flows uh
gold.com/goldcharting.
This is a quick five lesson course
on sort of the basics of of order flows.
Well, this is a free one.
Um you go to my website, there is the
order flow trading course.
It is a
It's a nice It's also a starting point
and gets into more advanced concepts
than you're going to get from
um this free course here.
Um
Nagaraja asked, how do we distinguish
all the features mentioned in order
flows trader if we enable all the
properties? Well, you're not going to
use all the properties all at once. Um
you shouldn't.
Because
you know, certain tools are meant for
momentum, certain tools are meant for
reversals
and it'd be like
you know,
uh
yeah, it'd be like basically adding
up
uh
you know, where is it here?
You know, all all these
different tools from
you know,
that are available in the FX study,
right? The
I I you're not going to add all these
different oscillators all at once even
though you got, you know, 30, 47. You're
not going to add all momentum tools all
at once.
You're going to see which ones resonate
with you the best and and go from there,
you know? And again, you know, on those
weekly sessions
that we're going to be starting in
September, you could ask me, you know,
what do I recommend for you know, you
got to tell me like how you trade, like
your you know, what sort of
what market you trade, um
you know, what sort of chart you look at
and go from there.
As opposed to it's not just about, oh, I
got all every these tools that you know,
I add them all up.
It's not about that.
Excuse me.
Um Toby asked,
if I want to pay a one-time fee for the
order flow trader like you have for
this, is there an option? Um
no.
Not at the moment. There's not an
option. We were
talking about it maybe in the future,
but for now
um
it's a it's a monthly subscription.
Uh Seth asked, can we trade 4-hour,
1-hour time frame using order flow
concepts
and hold the trade for a few days?
Well,
let's just
I'll just pull up a 1-hour chart.
Excuse me. Sorry for coughing here. Let
me drink some water.
Now,
the thing is, okay, trading
1-hour, 4-hour,
okay?
Here, right? You you can't see the
footprint. I'd have to expand it up like
this, but
there are certain tools that I like to
use for 1-hour and 4-hour time frame.
However,
I say 1-hour. I I honestly I've never
used or I've never even looked at order
flow on a 4-hour chart because
order flow
in my opinion
is best to use as fresh as possible,
okay?
Cuz you want to take advantage of the
anomalies that are taking place
in the order flow right now.
Right? You don't want to be waiting 4
hours, 5 hours.
Um
you know, for for something to start to
play out. This is a 1-hour chart. Okay,
now you can see things like thin prints,
right? Obviously levels that are holding
for, you know, a period of time. Let's
just look back to sort of yesterday
during or not yesterday, but last
Friday.
Okay, so obviously we have the number
the data coming out. You can see like
this is a thin print here.
Okay? Obviously multiple imbalances,
stacked imbalances coming in here as as
well. So,
you know, in my opinion, again, I I
think order flow is best used as quickly
as you find out what's happening in the
market. But again, you know, if you're
looking at things like the deltas,
right? There might be some information
you can glean off there.
Um but for me personally, 15 minutes is
about as as long out as I would go.
Um if you type in order flow in study,
you'll see a normal one and then order
flows trader premium. I'm asked about
the premium version and does it include
the new upgrades?
Do you have a release? Yeah, the premium
version has
what we have on the new version of NT,
okay?
Order flow can be used for swing trading
for months time holding. Generally, no.
Okay. Honestly, hit that sh- I I would
love to say yes, but in my opinion, no.
Okay. It's just It's just not cuz there
there's a lot of information that's
coming in. Really, order flow is is
meant to be used
on the shorter term, um you know, for
day trading, for
intraday trading, scalping, not
necessarily for longer term,
you know, holding. Okay. In the sense of
months or weeks or anything like that.
You know, so for example, right, this is
Swiss franc on a 1-hour chart. Okay.
Let's go back to where we are here.
Now, you can see, right, there's a lot
of bullish information. Like, these are
probably imbalances coming in here.
Bearish information, but it's constantly
changing. Okay.
All right, guys. Uh how do I get access?
Uh the last question here. Um Arga
asked, "How do I get access to the order
flow premium indicator as it is locked?"
You have to subscribe to it. So, again,
to subscribe to it,
I put the link in there,
orderflows.com/gocharting.
You just click on this link
here. So, you see, right, type in
orderflows.com/gocharting cuz they did
prepare me a special link. It's a little
bit uh long. Um
So, I I created a special page. And then
once you sign up, or you could just go
to the pricing page if you already have
an account,
and you can subscribe from down here.
But, you do need to have a GoCharting
account to access to subscribe to these
indicators. Okay.
And then once you do, um
you know, once you subscribe,
it will uh send an email out to
GoCharting, the admins, and they'll
they'll add you in there. Okay. All
right, everyone. Um thanks for coming
out.
You know, it's a Monday. Well, for me,
it's a Monday. And uh you know, again, I
appreciate your time. And hopefully, you
guys uh have learned a bit more about
the uh order flows trader
on GoCharting. You know, I'm trying to
find a time to do another one of these
presentations just to get a little bit
more in-depth and get you a little bit
more comfortable with it. So, hopefully,
towards the end of this week, I could uh
get another one of these scheduled for
you guys. So, thanks, everyone, and have
a great rest of your day. Bye-bye.